♪♪
[ Cheering, whistling,
and applause ]
-Let's get to the news.
The 94th Academy Awards
were held last night
and featured
the first live performance
of "We don't Talk About Bruno"
from the Disney musical
"Encanto,"
followed by an unbelievable live
performance of
"We Don't Talk About Jada."
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
Well, remember 24 hours ago when
we thought Timothée Chalamet's
sternum was the craziest thing
we'd see all night?
That's right.
Will Smith walked onstage
during last night's
Academy Awards show
and slapped Chris Rock
in the face.
And I got to say
the last thing I ever expected
to see at the Oscars was
a display of narcissism.
[ Laughter ]
We'll have more on this story
in a little bit,
but first let me
do the rest of the monologue,
which is kind of terrifying
now that I know
you can get slapped
for doing a bad joke.
[ Laughter ]
During his speech
on Saturday in Poland,
President Biden spoke directly
to the Russian people
and said that
President Vladimir Putin
was to blame for
Western economic sanctions.
'Cause if there's one thing
Biden loves,
it's pointing fingers.
[ Laughter ]
During a rally in Georgia
on Saturday,
Republican Congresswoman
Marjorie Taylor Greene
attacked Transportation
Secretary Pete Buttigieg
and said, "He and his husband
can stay out
of our girls' bathrooms."
Well, I can't believe I'm going
to say this -- she's right.
[ Laughter ]
Men use the men's bathroom.
She got --
she got one right.
According to a new report,
Supreme Court Justice
Clarence Thomas' wife, Ginni,
discussed ways to overturn
the 2020 election
with then-White House
Chief of Staff Mark Meadows.
But don't worry,
she'll get her comeuppance
when she's eliminated first
on "Dancing with the Stars."
[ Laughter ]
Pepsi --
You guys, Pepsi has --
[ Laughter ]
Pepsi has announced
a partnership with
the restaurant chain IHOP
to offer a Pepsi maple syrup.
Great if you love Pepsi,
but you wish it took half
an hour to pour one.
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
President Biden on Monday
announced the so-called
billionaire minimum income tax
as part of his 2023 budget --
specifically, the part
they'll have to cut out
before it will pass.
[ Laughter ]
President Biden yesterday signed
an anti-lynching bill into law
and not, as I would have hoped,
President Buchanan.
[ Laughter ]
After meeting with
Judge Ketanji Brown Jackson
yesterday for the second time,
Republican Senator Susan Collins
told reporters
she felt Jackson had met
her personal standard
for serving
on the Supreme Court,
which is blowing anything
under a .08 on a breathalyzer.
[ Laughter ]
The White House said yesterday
that it would not invoke
executive privilege
to shield Jared Kushner
from testifying
before the House committee
investigating
the Capitol attack.
And if indicted,
he could be tried as an adult.
[ Laughter ]
After it was reported
that former President Trump
may have communicated
during the Capitol attack
using so-called burner phones,
Trump released a statement
on Monday that said,
"I have no idea
what a burner phone is.
To the best of my knowledge, I
have never even heard the term."
[ Laughter ]
I love the way he always goes
a little too far
with his denials.
It's like if someone said,
"Hey, man, I haven't seen
your wife lately,"
and you said, "I wouldn't even
know how to poison someone."
[ Laughter ]
"And I sure as hell
don't own a shovel."
[ Laughter ]
After facing criticism
for his plan
to clear homeless encampments
from the city,
New York Mayor Eric Adams
told reporters yesterday,
"I'm like broccoli.
You're going to hate me now,
but you're gonna love me later."
Well, okay, but just speaking
for myself,
it's been 48 years on broccoli.
[ Laughter ]
According to a new study,
eating just two servings
of avocado a week
can reduce the risk of having
a heart attack by more than 20%.
So, yeah, still no such thing
as affordable healthcare.
[ Laughter ]
Two avocados a week?
Who's making
two-avocados-a-week money?
[ Laughter ]
Walgreens has announced plans
to open robot-powered
fulfillment centers
across the U.S.
to help fill prescriptions,
with each robotic pharmacist
able to complete
300 prescriptions an hour,
which will give you more time
to wait for someone
to come unlock the razors.
[ Laughter ]
[ As robot ]
Robot does not unlock razors.
[ Normal voice ] Come on,
you've got robot hands.
[ As robot ]
No, robot does not.
Only fill prescriptions.
That is Steve's job.
[ Normal voice ]
Where's Steve?
[ As robot ]
Steve is on break.
[ Laughter ]
No, robot --
[ Laughing ]
Steve never tell robot
where he is going.
[ Laughter ]
Make robot sad.
Steve robot best friend.
[ Laughter ]
[ Laughs ]
[ Normal voice ] According --
According to new reports,
Apple is set to make
10 million fewer AirPods
than anticipated this year
due to rising inflation,
so maybe think twice before
walking over a sewer grate.
"Aww!
Aw, man, my AirPod.
I don't got the money for more.
I already bought
my two avocados."
[ Laughter ]
And finally, in honor of Easter,
Disney World will offer
a so-called Boozy Bunny,
which features
a chocolate rabbit
filled with a bourbon drink.
It's the perfect treat
for people who shouldn't be
at Disney World.
[ Laughter,
cheers and applause ]
♪♪
President Biden spoke yesterday
with Ukrainian President
Volodymyr Zelensky
for nearly an hour.
Zelensky secured
$500 million in aid
and Biden somehow ended up
with a reverse mortgage.
[ Laughter ]
Intelligence officials
reportedly believe that
Russian President Vladimir Putin
has only recently learned how
poorly the invasion of Ukraine
has been going and is angry
with his military advisers.
And you can tell he's upset
because now the table
is even longer.
[ Laughter ]
House Minority Leader
Kevin McCarthy said yesterday
that Republican
Congressman Madison Cawthorn
admitted that claims
that his fellow lawmakers
had done cocaine and invited him
to orgies were exaggerated
and added that Cawthorn
told him he,
"Doesn't know what cocaine is."
Guys.
[ Laughter ]
You got to keep
your denials believable.
It's okay if you know
what cocaine is.
I mean, look at this guy.
[ Laughter ]
He knows what cocaine is.
Maybe he never did any.
But every guy
who looks like that
hangs out with eight other guys
who look exactly like that,
and one of them
always has cocaine.
"Oh, hold on. Yeah, no,
it's in my puffy vest."
[ Laughter ]
McCarthy also added that
Cawthorn has lost his trust,
which is tough because, once
you lose Kevin McCarthy's trust,
you almost immediately
get it back.
[ Laughter ]
Organizers of Sunday
night's Academy Awards
said in a statement yesterday
that Will Smith refused to leave
the Oscars
after slapping Chris Rock
and added that they,
"recognize we could have handled
the situation differently,"
like maybe hiring
younger security guards.
[ Laughter ]
[ As Pacino ]
You got to go!
[ Laughter ]
[ As De Niro ]
Got to go.
You got to go.
I don't think he's going to go.
[ Laughter ]
[ As Pacino ]
Whoa!
[ Light laughter ]
[ Laughter ]
New York Mayor Eric Adams spoke
at an event this week
about the status
of the coronavirus pandemic
and said, "Everyone
who moved to Florida,
get your butts back
to New York City."
Everybody?
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Let's not get carried away.
[ Laughter ]
Tomorrow is April Fool's Day.
April Fool's!
It's actually today,
because my show airs
at an ungodly hour
of the morning.
[ Laughter ]
And finally, according
to a new study,
men who eat
excessive amounts of meat
increase the risk
of becoming infertile.
So get ready for that
to be an excuse.
"Baby, we don't need condoms,
I just had ribs."
[ Laughter ]
And that was the monologue,
everybody.
♪♪
[ Cheering, whistling,
and applause ]